focus for us is finding out how our
adversaries are using big data against
us
foreign actors will view the 2020 US
elections as an opportunity to advance
their interests but I think China writ
large is the most significant
counterintelligence threat we face the
underlying political and economic
factors that facilitated the rise of
Isis persist there still is a
substantial military capacity that Kim
jong-un wields the Iranians are
considering taking steps that would
lessen their adherence to jpoa it's
always interesting the threat assessment
the intelligence leaders for the Trump
administration talking about threats
from around the world and sometimes
varying with the president's description
of some of those areas but what about
all of that let's bring in our panel
byron york chief political correspondent
of The Washington Examiner Marr lives
the national political correspondent of
National Public Radio I'm Alan Hemingway
senior editor at The Federalist Barnard
struck by the election focus there was a
lot on election interference chris ray
saying that not only did russia try in
2018 but they believe that Russia and
China are really going to try to step it
up in 2020 actually you know I think
perhaps the the scariest sentence and
the whole report was the one that said
China and Russia are more aligned that
at any point in the mid-1950s that is
not not good at all and you're right
about the the election interference on
the other hand I think we've been
expecting this for for at least four
four years now one of the things that I
thought was really striking about this
report was it a lot of it just wasn't
very surprising given the news that when
the report comes out and says that North
Korea wants to build nuclear weapons and
wants to build the missile delivery
systems to to to attack the United
States or somewhere else I mean the
shocking thing would have been if they
weren't so there was there was a lot of
news in here that we really already knew
yeah I mean Mara gives it context the
Trump administration the president may
point back to North Korea and say listen
they haven't fired missiles over Japan
we're still talking and they haven't
tested any nukes
are they developing more stuff that's
what the Intel people say right now
that's quite different than him tweeting
North Korea is no longer a nuclear
threat but I thought that was a pretty
serious warning they not only said that
North Korea was doing all those things
but they said that North Korea would not
give up their its nuclear weapons right
so that is setting the stage for this
upcoming meeting between the president
and Kim jong-un it's gonna be a lot
harder I think than maybe Donald Trump
thought to get North Korea to make the
kind of deal that he wants but I think
you've heard the intelligence community
say this before remember right after
Helsinki when they all came to the
briefing room at the White House to say
how seriously they took Russian and
other countries efforts to intervene in
elections so they've been clanging the
alarm bells for quite a while why would
you say I read the report as well and I
thought it was interesting how
frequently Russia and China were linked
together as the same threat it would
have been nice to see what percentage of
the threat comes from China what
percentage from Russia because it's hard
to determine which one is the greater
threat but historically speaking what
the US has always tried to do is make
sure that Russia and China are not in
cahoots together it's why sometimes
you're friendlier to China and sometimes
you're friendlier to Russia knowing that
when they work together that's that's a
combined adversary that is varied very
difficult here's the FBI director on
China we have economic espionage
investigations for example that's just
one piece of it in virtually every one
of our 56 field offices and the number
of those has probably doubled over the
last three or four years and almost all
of them not all of them but almost all
of them lead back to China which is
pretty substantial Byron yeah that was
that was really striking and it's one of
the things that contrary to a lot of the
headlines there was not a lot of
difference with the president's position
on that
so I mean here again there was this
emphasis on the the Intel Chiefs coming
out and
and disagreeing with the President on
all these fronts and yes there was some
of that well here's one here's one that
was clear I mean the ISIS depiction and
how its talked about right was a lot
different we have one against Isis we've
beaten them and we've beaten them badly
the group has returned to its guerrilla
warfare roots while continuing to plot
attacks and direct its supporters
worldwide Isis --nt is intent on
researching and still commands thousands
of fighters in Iraq and Syria my
amendment would acknowledge the plain
fact that al Qaeda Isis and their
affiliates in Syria and Afghanistan
continue to pose a serious threat mine
well this is one of those areas where
the president is speaking about what the
orders were for the Pentagon for our
involvement in Syria they were told to
make sure that I said Isis doesn't
control all that lands that it had
40,000 square miles and in fact as we
saw tonight it's down to one town that
is surrounded now if people want to
change what the what the determination
is for our why we are there they're more
than welcome to do that Congress is more
than welcome to make the case that we
should be at war in Syria for up to 18
years which is what we are currently in
Afghanistan for and make the case that
that that involvement makes sense and
that that expense of money and lives is
something that's in the US as interests
but as far as the question of whether we
achieved what we set out to do there's
no question that we did defeat Isis as a
as a land holder yeah and let's just
make clear there's not a lot of nuance
in the president's Twitter feed when he
says these things you know I mean and
and there's a lot of a lot of detail in
this case you know when it comes to
holding land to go from 40,000 miles to
one town that's currently surrounded by
fighters that is the objective we set
out to do that is what we did and it's
this creep of mission that enables
people to be in areas for decades or
more this changed idea about what it
takes to achieve victory